samedi et dimanche sont les journées
nationales de l'archéologie à cette
occasion tout près de 50 ans ne pourrez
découvrir la ferme dit c'est un site
archéologique est placé entre le
tremblay sur modise joie pour
pontchartrain et nos invités vont
m'expliquer précisément où ça se situe
cet incident qui a été ouvert depuis
2003 olivier blin bonjour d'archéologues
architectes et stéphane tillement
bonjour vous êtes médiatrice du
patrimoine
alors j'ai déjà c'est pas forcément
simple à trouver entre le tremblay et je
voir ses fans expliquer d'où se trouvent
sept sites archéologiques d'affaires me
dit alors il se situe route de bazoches
mais vraiment entre les communes du
tremblay sur mauldre et les gens contre
leur train de pointer spectateurs qui
sont intéressés pour découvrir ce site
est ouvert samedi et dimanche au public
cfoot de bazas est ok voilà où elle a
fait un peu de gps ce site il est dit a
été ouvert en depuis 2003 il a été
découvert en tout cas pourquoi il a été
ouvert et à quelle occasion d'écouter ça
remonte à quand même quelques années il
est ouvert 2003 à l'emplacement de la
ferme cistercienne enfin d'affaires me
dit c'est une ferme cistercienne qui
dépendait de l'abbaye des vaux de cernay
par contre sous cette femme cistercienne
et sur l'ensemble de la plaine de joie
on a une ville gallo romaine dont
quelques hectares avaient été fouillés à
l'époque par moi même mais sous le tracé
de la nationale 12
ça remonte aux années 94 98 en fait
voilà bon en fait depuis 84 ans
quasiment depuis dix ans je suis comme
ça et qu'on découvre des vestiges
gallo-romains ça doit faire quelque
chose d'un petit pincement wiba surtout
à ses attentes voilà on s'y attendait
entre guillemets dans le sens où il y
avait des présomptions en fait d'un site
très important mais
on s'attendait pas vraiment à trouver
une ville avec un tel état de
conservation et puis surtout on voit la
chapelle
avec un commentaire je les vois d'ici
mai ben voilà voilà un peu les ruines en
fait voilà la chapelle cistercienne sur
laquelle on a engagé donc un chantier de
restauration avec des jeunes de 2,2 de
l'union européenne enfin des jeunes de
partout même du monde entier d'ailleurs
même pas que le matériel on aime les des
chinois et des coréens qui viennent donc
on a une restauration en fait finalement
qui est en cours maintenant pour sauver
ce site 4 est en ruine bien sûr et donc
sous ce site comme je le disais on a les
vestiges gallo romains alors vous me
posiez la question de savoir si c'est
passionnant oui c'est passionnant parce
qu'on fait une allemand on connait rien
dans le sous sol on ne connaît pas ses
dents tout seul aujourd'hui sont des
chances et une plaine c'est c'est un
espace agricole il faut imaginer qu'il
ya 2000 ans en fait on avait une ville à
cet emplacement ya une ville sera peu
près une trentaine quarantaine
d'hectares ha oui on a du mal à imaginer
les petites villes n'ont pas l'habitude
qu'on a du mal à imaginer ça justement
c'est ça qui est intéressant est est ce
que dans les faits c'est ce que vous
avez retrouvé il ya des choses un peu
remarquable il ya des choses il
ya deux mille ans les objets du
quotidien lui là on trouve les éléments
de parure que les femmes pouvaient se
mettre en sortant le soir au théâtre
mais bien sûr on trouve les objets de la
vie quotidienne la céramique la
vaisselle etc version non mais par
contre il ya toujours des découvertes
intéressantes
c'est une découverte intéressante dans
le sens où on connaît très très mal ce
genre d'agglomération qui sont des
agglomérations rurales on n'est pas en
présence d'une grande capitale de citer
comme paris but est là mais c'est tout
l'intérêt en fait de ce site il est très
bien conservés donc il ya des
potentialités scientifiques et des
potentialités en terme de découvertes et
puis surtout et c'est ça qui est
intéressant ça nous ramène aux journées
nationales de l'archéologie c'est aussi
bien évidemment
le faire découvrir au public maintenant
aujourd'hui donc voilà c'est ça qui est
important oui stéphane thibault a
expliqué non un petit peu ce qui va se
passer pendant ces deux journées samedi
dimanche quand les gens ont bien compris
comment on arrive à la ferme
voilà c'est une plaisanterie les gros
qu'est ce qui va se passer il ya ce
qu'on va pouvoir vous rencontrer d'abord
vous oui oui nous poser toutes les
questions qui
s'allument on sera là en fait donc
samedi après midi et dimanche toute la
journée
en fait j'ai invité des artistes à venir
créer sur la ferme dite pour
voilà pour en fait montré un autre
regard on a le regard de l'archéologue
on a le regard de l'architecte parce
qu'il ya un projet justement de
restauration le but était d'amener un
autre regard donc d'amener des artistes
locaux qui ont déjà un réseau est de
faire découvrir le site pour les
journées de l'archéologie et aussi donc
mais comment ils vont découvrir des
estivants comment ils vont régler sur le
site internet intervient sur le site ils
ont créé des oeuvres authentiques ce qui
sont en rapport avec le site alors en
fait voilà moi je leur ai donné un thème
je les ai contactés au mois de novembre
je l'aurais donné un thème contraste à
la ferme me dit regarde artistes sur
l'archéologie on a longuement parlé on
s'est rencontrés ils vont intervenir
donc créer des oeuvres spécialement pour
la ferme dit qu'ils seront donc en lien
vraiment étroit avec la fermeté purement
culturel et ça veut dire que les gens
pourront aussi discuté avec des
archéologues leur expliquer un peu leurs
mythes m'améliorer les archéologues sur
le terrain et d'ailleurs on a des
animations aussi pour les enfants parce
qu'il faut confier aux enfants
évidemment donc il ya des animations qui
sont alors j'ai des collègues de
l'institut national de recherches
archéologiques préventives où je
travaille de l'inrap qui seront là pour
animer en fait donc des stands voilà
spécialement pour les enfants sur la
restitution des céramiques y aura aussi
un stand de ces rames de services de
fabrication en fait de céramique et puis
il y aura le site arcs de vie qui va
être ouvert donc on va montrer aussi des
vestiges archéologiques bien évidemment
alors il expliqué un petit peu son nom
et/ou de ces fouilles dire écoutez je
les ans après je lis sur fond de ces
mêmes ventes en baisse de 84 de ses
partants mais ça fait vraiment dix ans
maintenant qu'on a qu'on travaille sur
la ferme est de même on est
on est au bout d'une première série de
campagnes qui a permis d'identifier un
certain nombre de choses sur la ferme
elle même et puis sur des niveaux
archéologiques gallo romains en ce qui
concerne l'appel des périodes anciennes
et puis là actuellement on est rentré
dans une phase de publication et là on
essaye de s'orienter effectivement vers
un projet de
restauration de mise en valeur du site
voilà donc les fouilles vont reprendre
les années qui viennent mais pour
l'instant ils sont arrêtés parce que ben
c'est comme tout on a des instances
scientifiques qui nous réclament à nos
chercheurs de publier rendre public
donc mais tout à fait mais voilà il faut
qu'on s'y engagent à situation dès le
départ quand on prend des
responsabilités de cette nature on s'y
engage et voilà ça fait partie du jeu
jusqu'au bout d'une valorisation de
visite ça veut dire que à terme croyais
un musée qui pourraient ouvert on est
100 quand même l'importance du voilà
enfin c'est ainsi un site très important
fait aujourd'hui on est rentré dans le
parc naturel régional
qui s'est étendu en fait maintenant de
l'autre côté en fait de la nationale 10
s'est expliquée par une forte action
supplémentaire et c'est vrai ce site en
fait une amende maintenant s'inscrit en
fait non seulement effectivement dans un
territoire protégé mais également aussi
dans une problématique qui est un petit
peu dépassé aujourd'hui simplement le
strict les strictes limites en fait des
communes dans laquelle il s'inscrit et
donc là on est en train de discuter
justement pour essayer d'avoir dans
l'avenir en fait finalement une
perspective des perspectives en fait
finalement autour de ce site alors musée
c'est un grand mot mais non il faut
plutôt réfléchir à un centre
d'interprétation enfin à quelque chose
qui permettent au public de comprendre
en fait l'histoire du lieu comprendre le
territoire dans lequel il s'inscrit et
moi je l'espère aussi enfin présenté
tous les justement magnifique mobley
mais qu'on a trouvé qu'ils sont quand
même dans le dernier vendée qui dorment
dans des dépôts de l'état aujourd'hui et
qui serait alors il serait bien
évidemment sont sortis de terre il faut
qu'elles soient nettoyées sont étudiées
photographier nettoyer publiées mais
après l'idéal c'est qu'effectivement
elle soit versée elle s'engage et samba
n'ont pas forcément parce qu'elles vont
elles ont été présentées une centre
attend on a été présenté à l'exposition
qui a vu à versailles il ya quelques
années à versailles au service
départementale des yvelines mais
également aussi à versailles il ya des
pièces qui sont présentées au musée de
saint germain en laye voci également
donc voilà donc oui oui voilà donc en
fait c'est s'est jamais complètement
cachée au public mais ce qui serait
intéressant c'est de les regrouper en
fait vraiment dans un espace qui
permettent de valoriser le site il ya
une association pour la promotion du
site archéologique qui s'appelle jo de
rome la ville de
cette association qui regroupe une
soixantaine
d'adhérents
qu'est ce qu'ils font ces adhérents ils
ont droit de fouiller la terre de
gratter la terre oui le droit d'être des
archéologues bénévoles oui oui l'amf
être archéologue bénévole à la ben saad
il suffit d'adhérer et on peut devenir
archéologue bénévole on élève si on n'a
pas de diplôme même si on sait pas faire
une amende harris as et c'est la passion
dans la tradition du oui en fin de
chantier bénévole le site a été un été
chantier école pour les universités donc
pour les étudiants tout simplement
qu'ils ont besoin d'apprendre à fouiller
mais évidemment il est ouvert aussi à
tous les bénévoles qui sont intéressés
par l'archéologie et qui désirent
découvrir alors on va dire que la grande
majorité de nos bénévoles paradoxalement
c'est surtout des retraités en fait
voilà donc céder tout jeune archéologue
comme vous l'imaginez
et qui bat voilà qu'il se passionne pour
le passé
non mais c'est des gens qui se passionne
pour le patrimoine tout simplement parce
qu'il ya un respect effectivement
archéologiques stricto sensu bon qui lui
est une part du travail mais par contre
derrière il ya effectivement aussi le
sauvetage de tous les bâtiments de la
ferme ya un hectare de bâtiments donc
avec des éléments dont on a pu mettre en
évidence le côté tout à fait
exceptionnel qui s'apparente d'ailleurs
aux techniques de construction ou homo
dénaturant fait qu'on a sur la bd votre
cerner donc on a une architecture tout à
fait intéressante à sauver et donc c'est
à dire pour chercher toujours des
bénévoles
une adore question qu'est ce qui vous a
donné envie de devenir un archéologue
ces familles alors
la passion de pouvoir comprendre en fait
les skis c'est ce qui s'est passé avant
et comprendre pourquoi ça c'est ça c'est
peut-être effondré des choses comme ça
et pouvoir appliquer les conseils
pourquoi pas la société d'aujourd'hui
parce que c'est un métier qui fait qui
fait rêver on a l'impression que c'est
un peu le temps suspendu dans une
société moderne qui va vite quoi c'est
probablement faire est ce que vous dites
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on a
peut-être un peu de fonctions de se
poser et puis de découvrir des choses
comme ça c'est intéressant à
l'archéologie c'est qu'on ne sait pas ce
qu'on va découvrir donc en fait même à
l'échelle de son petit carré de fouilles
on a toujours l'espoir de de découvrir
quelque chose de tout à fait
exceptionnel et c'est vrai que ça arrive
d'ailleurs tous les jours
les découvertes archéologiques se font
comme ça la plupart du temps donc on est
on est on est quelque part dans une
démarche de découverte permanence
absolument pas ce qu'il va y avoir dans
le sol juste un passionnant qu'est ce
qui vous a donné envie de venir chez moi
j'avais toujours eu envie de faire
l'histoire me m'intéressait alors que le
gym était assez quand j'étais tout petit
après j'ai comme beaucoup de gens
d'ailleurs j'ai fait des études
d'architecturé parce que ça
m'intéressait
l'architecturé antique m'intéressait
et puis voilà le fil en aiguille on
arrive à faire ton arrive toujours à
faire se trouvait qu'on a envie de le
faire
cette
lettre je rappelle si vous voulez
découvrir la ferme archéologiques dit
c'est samedi et dimanche à l'occasion
des journées nationales de l'archéologie
merci à vous deux